I have observed as many others have many
times that despite anyone's gender
identity quote unquote the fact is that
when they die and I said this on Dr Phil
I said what is a woman uh you know when
you die and are buried in the ground and
your flesh rots away leaving only your
bones
all that will be left
almost all is your sex no matter how you
identified when archaeologists and
anthropologists of the future exhume
your grave and look at your remains they
will declare you male or female
your self-identity will be gone but your
sex will remain this is how deeply
embedded it is it is the last thing
about you that anyone will be able to
know
just as is one of the first things about
you that anyone will be able to know
well all of that remains true I mean
none of that has ever changed has
changed or ever will the only adjustment
that uh we have to make now
is in the assumption that archaeologists
and anthropologists of the future will
actually be free and willing to make
these kinds of statements about people
of the past
a report in the college fix suggests
otherwise
it says quote as soon as ancient human
remains are excavated archaeologists
begin the work of determining a number
of traits about the individual including
age race and gender
but a new school of thought within
archeology is pushing scientists to
think twice about assigning gender to
ancient human remains it is possible to
determine whether a skeleton is from a
biological male or female using
objective observations based on the size
and shape of the bones criminal forensic
detectives for example do it frequently
in their line of work but gender
activists argue scientists cannot know
how an ancient individual identified
themselves
quote uh you might know the argument
that the archaeologists who find your
bones one day will assign you the same
gender as you had at Birth so regardless
of whether you transition you can't
escape your assigned sex tweeted
Canadian master's degree candidate Emma
Palladino last week Paladino who's
seeking an advanced degree in archeology
called assigning gender to an ancient
human Bolt quote labeling remains male
or female is rarely the end goal of any
excavation anyway wrote paldino the bio
archeology of the individual is what we
aim for factoring in absolutely
everything we discover about a person
into a nuanced and open-ended biography
of their life
now it's not just one whack job saying
this it's many whack jobs there's a
whole movement in the field now to
conform the work of anthropology with
the demands of trans activists the fix
continues quote gender activists have
formed a group called the trans doe task
force to explore ways in which current
standards in forensic human
identification do a disservice to people
who do not clearly fit the gender binary
we propose a gender expansive approach
to human identification by combing
missing an unidentified databases
looking for contextual Clues such as um
descendants wearing uh clothing
culturally coded to a decedence rather
wearing clothing culturally coded to a
gender other than their assigned sex the
group's mission statement reads quote we
maintain our own database of missing and
unidentified people who we've determined
may be transgender or gender variant as
most current databases systems do not
permit comparison of missing to
unidentified across different binary sex
categories to the group rights
uh which which by the way means that are
we talking about the forensic element of
this uh forensic detectives people
working cold cases and everything if
they really apply this it makes their
work impossible it's you can't do it
anymore
because usually you find the remains of
someone and then you try to match them
with a database figure out who it is you
know who are these remains and then you
can figure out how they died well in
order to match them you first one of the
things you have to know is okay well the
age race and sex and then you take that
and then you go to the database of
missing people you say okay well this
matches that person
but if they're looking at the remains
and saying well we don't know their sex
we have no idea we can't possibly know
this is just a person
then there's no way to narrow it down
and ever match that person with a
missing person which means that the
whole field of cold cases forensic work
all of that is just out the window
including the entire field of
anthropology and Archeology all of it is
done out the window along with the
dictionary and reality itself a little
more here from the fix it says this
February University of Kansas associate
professor Jennifer RAF published origin
a genetic history of the Americas in
which she argued that there are no neat
divisions between physically or
genetically male or female individuals
rafts adjusted suggested scientists
cannot know the gender of a 9 000 year
old biologically Peruvian Hunter because
they don't know whether the hunter
identified as male or female a duality
concept she says was quote imposed by
Christian colonizers
well she's right in a way nobody can
know the gender of a 9 000 year old
Peruvian Hunter because nobody 9000
years ago or 900 years ago or 90 years
ago had a gender the concept hadn't been
invented yet and imposed On The World by
woke leftist pervert colonizers that's
the only kind of colonizing that really
happens anymore in the west anyway
everyone back in those days had only a
sex and that was it they may have had
different words in different languages
to communicate it obviously but there
were people who got pregnant and people
who did the impregnating and those were
the two categories
the only two firm categories any society
has ever had until ours these activists
disguised as scientists recognize this
reality and they see the problem it
creates for them because this is one of
the things one of the questions they've
found it so difficult to answer I mean
they find every question difficult to
answer but especially this one which is
why should anyone
listen to your rambling nonsense that
you just came up with a few years ago
like why should we care
you came up with this stuff a few years
ago why should I care about that why
should anyone care about it
why should we allow you to redefine
Concepts that have endured for millennia
for Millennia billions of people have
lived lived and died and had no problem
with these categories have not caused
any problems for them it's been it has
not caused any confusion and then you
come along and you you want to change
all of this
and not only change it for yourselves
but but insist that everyone else has to
look at it differently
well they can't explain why we should do
that so
they seek to rewrite history and
superimpose their ideological fixations
onto the past even the very ancient past
I mean the level of narcissism on
display here is Monumental psychotic
unfathomable
they now wish to perform a sort of
posthumous baptism on the entire human
race christening everyone
all of our ancestors in the waters of
gender Theory
rewriting the history and lives and
Legacies of all of our ancestors in
order to justify their modern day sexual
fixations and fetishes
I mean it was bad enough when they
condemned all of our ancestors as bigots
and racists and transphobes refusing to
give them the grace of historical
context that was bad enough
what they seek to do now is so much
worse
rather than condemn the ghosts of our
great great grandparents they'll instead
recruit them
enlist them
to the LGBT cause against their will
a sort of posthumous conscription
a Selective Service of the Dead if you
will
they seek not only to build their own
reality in their own universe but to
extend their reach across space as well
as time into the past
and then on to the present and out
towards the future
and they can do all of this
or at least attempt it
but the truth remains no matter what
and it falls to us to defend it against
all threats
I know you're craving some more Matt
Walsh show content while I have some
great news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com And subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast I'll see you there